[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain a chinese science
fiction short film called scissors
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
the movie begins as we see a montage of
a messed up apartment junk food wrappers
and empty soda cans are lying all around
cigarettes are scattered on the table
and magazines are thrown on the floor it
is night time and a guy is present in
the room who is sitting next to his
computer looking at something with great
focus
we also notice a lot of women's posters
on the wall which implies that the guy
is single or perhaps in his first year
of college just then the clicking of the
mouse intensifies and the guy starts
sweating profusely his eyeballs are
stuck onto the screen and his heartbeat
starts racing fast turns out that the
guy is just watching adult movies and
enjoying his solitude after he finishes
the deed he cleans himself up with some
tissue paper and throws it on the floor
even for a beta male bachelor that's
disgusting after his magical moment the
guy simply drops to his bed turns off
the light and goes to sleep
in this scene we can notice a lot of
tissue paper lying on the floor meaning
that the guy always practices the same
feat every night suddenly there is a
knock on the door the guy is confused as
to who could possibly visit him at this
time of night perhaps it's the fap
police he asks who is outside but when
no one replies he reluctantly has to
wake up the guy then lazily gets out of
his bed puts on his vest and goes
outside to check he opens the door and
looks everywhere but surprisingly finds
no one thinking that someone has pranked
him he prepares to go back inside when
he notices a mysterious box lying on the
floor apparently someone had dropped it
off and left without a trace despite
finding the situation very strange the
guy simply picks up the mystery box and
goes back inside his room he puts the
box down on the table and slowly opens
it inside it he finds a normal looking
pair of scissors and a paper with an
apple drawn on it he checks the scissors
but it is functioning like any normal
scissors would out of curiosity the guy
takes out the paper from the box and
starts cutting the apple from it despite
having some horrible cutting skills he
manages to get the apple out and after a
bit of staring he places it on the table
and leaves the guy then heads towards
his bookshelf where he checks an empty
soda can and smells it too after
confirming that it doesn't have any soda
in it he simply chucks it away between
the books he also checks some empty chip
packets lying around in hopes of getting
something to eat but to his dismay
everything is empty maybe he should stop
having jerk chicken for dinner as he is
starving from hunger he suddenly notices
that the apple cut out on the table has
turned into a real apple
initially the guy can't believe his eyes
but since he is super hungry he simply
gives the apple a few rubs on his vest
and starts eating it making loud sounds
after taking a few bites the guy is sure
that the apple is real and he quickly
rushes to the mysterious box to examine
it he checks the box in every possible
manner but doesn't find anything else he
then starts wondering to himself if the
whole situation is real he also ponders
as to who could have dropped this
special gift for him the confused guy
then picks up the magic scissors and
looks at them closely to find anything
unusual once again the scissors look
perfectly normal with no weird signs
whatsoever however the guy is not
content with it so in an attempt to
prove that the scissors are magical the
guy starts looking around for something
to cut into he then finds a piece of
paper with a picture of a cup filled
with coffee he wastes no time and
immediately starts cutting the image out
of the paper while he is doing so he
looks scared but at the same time very
focused after he successfully gets the
cutout he holds it in his hand and waits
for it to transform into the real object
but nothing happens
thinking it was just a mere
hallucination the guy smirks and tosses
the cutout in the air but when he turns
around he finds that the cup and coffee
have miraculously turned real
the cup smashes onto the floor and the
coffee is splattered everywhere along
with glass shards we even get to know
that the coffee is hot exactly as shown
in the picture as steam was rising out
of the coffee the guy is stunned by this
and he hurriedly bends down to inspect
the coffee after tasting it he verifies
that it is real and once again gives a
smirk which signals that he is happy
with the revelation and who wouldn't be
he's probably about to carve himself out
a new box of tissues the guy then gets
the scissors and starts playing with
them and this time he has a wide smile
on his face it seems that he has found
all the solutions to his problems and he
is ready to live his life with the
utmost fun with that being said the only
thing that keeps him awake all night is
his fantasies about girls hence he has
only one plan on his mind and there is
no stopping him now
in order to initiate his plan he goes
near the wall and rips out a girl's
poster from it unfortunately for him he
also ripped the girl's head which makes
him upset but no problem there are
plenty more posters where that came from
he then turns to the next poster of a
stunning girl and starts smirking
menacingly he is already imagining his
time with her here we get to know that
the guy is in desperate need of a
partner he knows that there may be risks
involved in the experiment but he is
willing to go through all of it to
fulfill his fantasies after retrieving
the poster he carefully places it on his
bed so that he doesn't tear it this time
the guy then begins the cutting process
bit by bit he starts trimming the
beautiful girl from the picture he is
cutting with maximum concentration as he
doesn't want the girl to be lacking in
any body parts he also gets more and
more excited as he cannot wait to meet
the girl of his dreams just as he is
about to finish the task he gets a call
from someone which distracts him
momentarily when he turns around to
resume the cutting he finds out that he
accidentally chopped off the girl's head
with the magic scissors the accident
worries him a lot as he knows the
consequences that he is going to face
in an attempt to save himself the guy
immediately tries to attach the two
pictures and he rushes to his drawer to
find some tape while he searches through
his things haphazardly we can see the
fear in his eyes
finally after a bit of searching the guy
gets his hands on some tape and breathes
a sigh of relief as the guy tries to
return to the bed he slips on the
dropped coffee and falls on the floor
the careless guy is hurt from the fall
and as he gathers himself up he notices
someone's legs next to him it is the
girl that he cut out and she has now
come to life just as he desired
suddenly something drips on his head and
as he looks up he is shocked to see
blood oozing out of the girl the blood
drips directly on his head which leaves
him scared to death it is because she
has no head attached to her the guy then
turns around and notices the girl's
severed head lying on the bed even the
head is dripping with blood the eerie
head seems lifeless but is smiling and
staring directly into his eyes it is in
this moment that he really begins
wishing that he had stuck to only fans
tonight the movie ends as blood keeps
dripping onto the guy's head as he is
hypnotized by the girl's stare what the
hell did we just watch
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out